we were the number one show on nbc
for most of the time that we were on so
ten years nine seasons the first two
we struggled mightily um
but
for most the time we went but we were
never like we never thought of ourselves
and i know that our collective
experience was in the nbc
you know pantheon of these shows so like
seinfeld or cheers or friends for sure
we were never that we were like
a solid hit right now for nbc that
doesn't have a lot else on the air
that's truly how we were treated by nbc
and that's that's what we were
um
and
then
three four years ago now
streaming numbers start coming out
and
my experience walking through an airport
or being out in public
suddenly is way more intense than it
ever even was back when we were on
thursday nights every year wow
and that was the entire experience of
the book of starting the podcast was
really based on that question which was
why why
why is this why is this happening
because it is one of the biggest hits in
the history of television well now
now
more people are watching it now than any
other show in television like think
about that that's insane so you know you
still have the cover what stranger
things or you know
whatever the hit streaming show of the
moment is
more people are watching the office that
are watching those shows still
that's
remarkable it's in i know it's insane
and so that for me was it which is why
is that why why is this happening what
and can we go back and can we
deconstruct
decisions that were made that maybe have
made it
yeah and not just survive this long but
actually now be thriving again
like michael we were not making a show
for kids this was not a con this was not
a conversation yeah like we were like oh
if people who work in an office can
maybe relate to it then we'll be okay
like we'll stay on the air right
and
but like the kids are watching it it's
crazy
that is just insane